I want to talk about double standards Ignorance
and general depravity.
And No, I'm not talking about the Colin segment
during Sean Hannity's radio show today.
I'm talking about that infamous trump tower
meeting.
There are sort of two conflicting arguments
from Donald Trump, not surprisingly, about
the trump tower meeting that happened with
this Russian lawyer, Natalia vessel in that
sky, uh, with the purpose of getting dirt
on Hillary Clinton to help trump win the election
meeting.
Uh, one, the first one is the meeting was
totally legal.
Collusion isn't a crime.
The other is it's actually hillary who colluded
with Russia and she should be investigated,
which of course you would only do if it was
a possible crime that was committed yesterday
on the show.
We focused on the second one, right?
The countless claims from Donald trump that
hillary colluded with Russia and should be
investigated by Robert Mueller or the FBI
or law enforcement, or whoever's willing to
do it today.
I want to focus more on the other part of
the argument, which is that the meeting at
trump tower with Russians promising dirt on
Hillary Clinton was illegal.
As Donald Trump has claimed.
And this goes back to donald trump's tweet
over the weekend, we're Donald Trump admitted
for the first time that the point of the trump
tower meeting with Russians was not to talk
about adoptions, but to get dirt on Hillary
Clinton.
And Donald Trump said in this tweet, quote,
fake news reporting, a complete fabrication
that I am concerned about.
The meeting my wonderful son Donald had in
trump tower.
This was a meeting to get information on an
opponent totally legal and done all the time
in politics.
And it went nowhere.
I did not know about it.
There is an excellent article in the, I believe
it's the La Times written by former US attorney
and current law professor Harry Litman, along
with David Lieberman, where they explain the
meeting was not totally legal.
Meeting with a foreign power to get help with
an American presidential election isn't legal.
And this is one of the most precise explanations
of the possible criminality I've read so far.
And I encourage you to read it as well.
There's a federal law 18 us code subsection
three 71 called conspiracy to commit an offense
against or to defraud.
The United States, some of those Russians
indicted by Robert Molar already were charged
under this specific law, and the defrauding
of the United States can include, quote, any
conspiracy for the purpose of impairing, obstructing,
or defeating the lawful function of any department
of government, even if the object of the conspiracy
is not a criminal offense.
Let's see if we can unpack that a little bit.
The object of becoming president doesn't need
to be a criminal offense.
I mean it isn't right.
Trying to be president is not illegal, but
conspiracy to obstruct the way that the Federal
Election Commission says elections are supposed
to run, for example, not allowing foreign
nationals to contribute to elections, including
both money and things of value like dirt on
Hillary.
That's still a crime even if your end goal
becoming president is not illegal in and of
itself.
There's another really important part of conspiracy
law.
Not only is the objective not relevant, the
success of the conspiracy doesn't matter.
Trump, even in that tweet I put up for you
insists he never got the dirt on Hillary from
Russia according to the law, uh, as Lipman.
And Lieberman explain as long as you agreed
to pursue the dirt on Hillary from Russia,
conspiracy has been committed and littman
and Lieberman argue that the trump tower meeting
fits the description of conspiring to defraud
the United States regardless of whether they
got the dirt or didn't this ads, by the way,
to the speculation that don junior is in legal
trouble, trouble Lipman and Lieberman, right?
That molar just based on what's publicly known,
could likely already in indict Donald Trump
junior.
So he should be very worried, even though
trump is saying he's not at all worried because
it was totally legal and they didn't get the
dirt.
Anyway.
Actual law professors say no, Donald trump
jr should be worried.
And that's what we've been thinking for the
last two or three months.
But it's going to come down to prosecutorial
discretion, right?
It's whether or not Miller wants to press
charges against Don Jr for this because I
mean, you know, we, we kind of joke about
this whole, uh, they had never worked on a
campaign thing, but that is true to some degree.
Like maybe he didn't know that that was criminal.
And we don't want to press charges on him
because of this.
You're referring to sort of like the intent
element that is there when it comes to crimes
in the way that this law appears to be written,
regardless of whether you know that it's against
the law to do this, regardless of whether
what you want help to do isn't illegal, which
in this case it's not becoming president,
that it would still be a crime for which one
could be indicted.
But you are right.
I mean regardless, ultimately there's going
to be significant, a gray area here for prosecutors
to figure out who do they want to charge.
And with what.
And as you know, this is just about what the
public knows.
I'm sure there's a lot more than just the
trump tower meeting, so we'll have to see.
Not only that, our entire discussion today
has been just about conspiracy to defraud.
We haven't even touched on possible obstruction
of justice or witness tampering and other
crimes and hopefully molar is looking, looking
into those.
But again, merely on the public knowledge
about the trump tower meeting, we have legal
experts increasingly agreeing that a try,
a crime likely has been committed here.
We'll see if trump's lawyers can clean it
up for him.